a new limited edition hat black and
yellow black and yellow ten days
starting right now
you guys missed out on our last half
here's another chance to get your very
own limited edition court or digital hat
you know anyone who likes a set or even
like yourself
Snagit can make a great gift or a great
thing to put on your head day isn't
Christmas coming up yeah it is you know
what else is coming up Thanksgiving know
what else is coming up
New Year's November 3rd corridor -
digital comm slash store slash store
click on the link it's here it's there
it's up here it's down there everywhere
I mean for just just just spend two
seconds looking for it you'll find it I
swear when you're shooting with a robot
or anything that's electronic you just
never quite know what its gonna do it's
not broken but worst case no I'm not
gonna say it because remember last time
when I said we were ahead
oh hey we got the little robot company
Anke makes this thing called a Cosmo and
a little emotive tank treaded robot the
little light-up face and pox and moves
around and does weird stuff professor in
the video with this thing as a character
because it's very expressive I'm working
on these little robot dogs get a pass
history - Sam wanted like a rusted color
today he said if you want a bit more
color to it as if I was fading and the
rust was taking over I am painting these
guys more of a brighter color I got a
little tractor from the next video
[Music]
sometimes if you go to the right places
this is clearly a sort of family-owned
venture here a lot of times you could go
to those companies and you just ask if
you can talk to the owner they'll let
you film there that's kind of what we
did here we got lucky
because it was the first place we went
to but it's also right by the studio
it's really really convenient this is
definitely better yeah because it's not
there's more more detail panorama is
taking little panorama as at ground
level so that when we go back and start
planning things out I got reference
images here that a kind of at ground
level the backdrops for what we would
see on screen eventually taking pictures
up here isn't gonna really prove useful
we're not shooting people we're shooting
little tiny toy robots I don't know what
this is it's a toilet oil yeah from the
forklift you just smell it oh do that so
grody what right there just to see how I
can lump of it yeah
[Music]
and remember to bring those macro lenses
look alright yes whoa hi welcome to the
same and eco channel if you have not
subscribed consider doing so because I
am about to shoot a fully charged flight
boat with this bow and arrow but not in
this video subscribe if you want to see
it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm controlling this little Aki Cosmo
hunky hunky Cosmo robot it's pretty cool
this has this thing is like a lot of
emotion that comes out of it so I'm
trying to do right now is take all the
all the beats that this thing needs to
hit going through all the key animations
that are preset in this it has a ton
black magic micro camera that's what I'm
using cool camera it's nice and small
just like these little toys finding this
really handy it's really cool because
it's not just because it's small but
it's also because it's really low to the
ground really nice to be able to get
down there really easily with that
perspective to gain so they want me to
grow my beard back don't come back
unless your beard is nice and thick its
back we're doing about to do the first
shot with the Cosmo but when you're
shooting with a robot or anything that's
electronic you just never quite know
what it's gonna do I grab him he's just
walking robots dude oh he's freaking out
look his life it doesn't harm you Cosmo
has a wife I can actually we have to
capture the phone to when we connect the
phone to the Apple and then from that we
open up like a command log and then we
can take control the robot from there
and if we can't connect it to the phone
that we can't connect it to the computer
take the robot so gonna make our way
down the maker Wi-Fi is off here Wi-Fi
is out there the only thing that's
searching is that I'm just going to
leave them sit don't touch anything for
like two minutes
so though that I think it just glitched
out
throughout a USB charger please all the
other robots look over Diggs and they're
like reshoot all that [ __ ] out and then
probably will maybe shoot a little
excavator stuff hopefully by the time
things have sorted out doing the best I
can
why isn't the phone call
as if you're watching the cosmic drive
towards the exit
[Music]
sans drinking another soda in the last
odor he said I should be drinking this
soda I overslept this morning so I kind
of tired so I'm just chugging soda
90,000,000 right now for any sort of
conduit you're working perfectly fine
yesterday let's see what happens oh yeah
reset him oh he's just like shorted okay
he shorted it on the bottom with two
wires that turn it off I can connect to
him uh-oh oh yeah that's right securing
oh all right
awesome that was okay thank you so much
we have a lot to film so we're gonna get
at it and thank you again I'll call you
anything else happens anything else
happens anything else happens everything
that's connected to the phone or else it
wouldn't be on what's wrong after recent
wait why why what's wrong I can't open
it
I can't open me it might be because he's
just on the ground there's a lot of
metal on the ground it's connected to
the phone or else it wouldn't be on oh
wait hold on hold on it's connected over
there actually doesn't turn on the
terminal robot not connected
small problem he so he's booting up
everything's working with that but we're
gonna open up the app on the phone it's
just going to a black screen that says
not connected oh come on
with it said 10 to 15 minutes for full
charge so nice okay I'm just gonna let
it like charge up a hits that seemed
like it was actually dying over there
though we're simply staying on the chart
now he's going into which mode again no
yeah immediately he's terminal no no no
you keep it you deal with the laptop is
the last stage you deal with this you do
this and you deal with this really
glitch mode try it in here you know what
they're like yeah at this point in the
you know it could be anything right
[Music]
hey here we are at the junkyard mark
okay do you see anything like I thought
you said yeah I mean I kill anything
okay
oh [ __ ] oh whoa I thought you had us and
it's great all right what was the pike
that was it
there's some sort of script that was
bugged out in the background that wasn't
fully quitting when we were okay
sweet that is awesome thank you sorry
all right man thanks for the help I
really appreciate it thank you thank you
man yes that was mark with the
engineering team at on Keith's mark
oh thank you yeah mark Ozzie good cool
all right it's crushing and then and
then it and then yeah so we got it
working but then half the time every
time we would use an emotion it would
then would get stuck in a loop but we
get better you have a problem so we're
having this problem all day and one of
the last shots and the piece is these
robots going outside and they're free of
a junkyard back in reality yeah they're
like a we are free gag at the end is
that a car giggling hmm
and they're not paying attention and a
car like Clips one of the toys and that
you robots like an over reality problem
is that her stunt driver today we had a
problem with a stunt driver let's just
say we all right so this is really nice
guy Alfonso that was running the the
location that we were at and he works
there and he was hired to be there for
the day while we were shooting there and
at the end we had this truck and I
didn't bring my pickup which was the
original plan that I would clip one of
Jake's go why didn't you bring it
because I forgot you know be really cool
if that truck clipped the toy I go will
you do it and he goes yeah I get him
there and he's gonna he's gonna do the
he's gonna do the thing but he's a liver
so he inches up to the toy yes and and
it like it's one mile an hour and I'm
like what he didn't like they they back
the truck up and Jake saying like you
just run him over I'm like Jake say run
over the dog he backs up and we record
speed and you get to be working up some
speed and the first tire the first start
goes through the toy retired and barely
missing a perfect shot perfect shot
mmm-hmm the promise is that the second
tire will multiple tires with eight
tires in the back because it's two
double stacked tires in the back of the
truck yeah and that thing is there like
this wide so they won't believe it it's
heading straight for the toys
and it looks like it's gonna just miss
the Anki and keep going and hit the
other ones I'm like oh god no no I
didn't stop him because the I saw the
first tire and it was clearly gonna miss
it but I forgot that in the back and
anything in that range a radius Scott
crushed we got a shot and all the stuff
got ran over
including the Anki robot it's it was
just it was a he was a pancake and all
the toys got ran over the entire group
everyone negative for the toy I was
supposed to get ran over
yeah
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] god damn it
hahahaha canceled [ __ ] BBA uh also
feeling like enemies out there who
really hate our channel what better way
to make them angry and get revenge than
to get them a corridor digital hat or
hack maybe amend a relationship